all right cody yep cody where'd you grow
up where are you from originally uh pogo
west virginia and tell me about uh your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were a kid yeah
how would you describe your childhood um
they grow like they worked a lot so like
me and my sister like we had a good
relationship up until she started doing
drugs and then yeah it kind of brought
me in the situation when i was like 13.
you started with his drugs as well uh
yeah and then it just like progressed
from there you know i just started
smoking weed and then you know it went
to heroin addiction but
um
yeah like i was through 10 being a
teenager
i had a kid when i was 17
and
you know i had her for
three years and then her mom we broke up
and
you know it didn't have her as much
and that you know what made my drug
addiction worse because i didn't have
time you know my time spent with his
like my kid as much
so
and
really i lost rights like a month ago
because she had another kid and it had
heroin in the system
and now we're fighting you know for that
so it's all messed up
but yeah
uh
my childhood was it was good really
growing up with my parents and stuff but
it just yeah
them working so much and not having time
to be around around
made more you know yeah so it wasn't
like you had this traumatic terrible
childhood trying to numb the pain from
it's just
it just
yeah it seems very common out here for
guys your age to be involved in drugs
yeah
what do you think the cause of that is
um
there's nothing to do really
just
learning too much stuff to do around
here
so you
take your time and yeah eventually a
weekend comes around where yeah where
you know you
if you smoke weed if you just make weed
you know it's going to bring you around
to other drugs sooner or later because
it's not legal here so yeah and the main
drugs that people use i hear are heroin
and what else meth crystal meth yeah
how do you support yourself um
just you know making money as a white
house i can and
pretty much you know paying to sleep
somewhere
so you're just crashing where you can
yeah right now yeah i'm actually
supposed to be going into a rehab center
here in the next couple days oh is that
right yeah
how old are you 25 25
have you been using since 13 yeah wow
you finished high school uh no i dropped
out when i was in ninth grade
yeah you've had jobs yeah i've had
plenty of jobs but you know drug
addiction kind of
messed up a lot of those too right
yeah because it comes first
with a lot of them
do you have dreams of doing something
with your life when you were younger uh
yeah like i wanted to do something like
animals
because i like animals a lot i like
animals more than people
most of the time
what's your biggest regret uh probably
uh starting heroin
that's probably my worst regret yeah i
mean do you blame your sister for that
or do you blame yourself i blame myself
because i chose to do it you know i
could have said no
right but of your of your
friends and people that are your age
down here how many what percentage
roughly do you think might be
using like you are
95 of my friends
pretty much 95. wow yeah
that's an incredible number yeah
well you think it's just the boredom of
nothing to do and
the drugs are available yeah this is
more drugs and
you know and you can find those then
it's easier to you know numb your time
than it is to it's hard to find a job
yeah
yeah
what about leaving the area
uh
i don't know someone living area with
the whole thing with my daughter right
now
so i can't leave the area until
i figure that out oh i see
but i'm leaving there for rehab just so
i mean you know i can't just be around
it you know
so i can hopefully at least get a little
bit time away from here
what do you think of the future of this
part of the country with with drugs
being so uh oh
it's gonna keep happening until they do
something about it yeah it seems like
that your generation is almost doomed
yeah it's that's this is one of the
bigger like this state has one biggest
struggle epidemic series
it's out of control for real yeah
you can't stop it
would you consider yourself
self-destructive
uh yeah
i i i become something i hate
the shame of of not being there for your
child and that and just your life is
kind of falling apart yeah it just
revolves around one thing and it's
heroin yeah for real is this the lowest
point in your life right now yeah for
real
what was the best time your life uh
probably when i was a kid
i don't remember much of it but i know i
was happy
yeah but even a happy childhood
doesn't protect you from
getting into this stuff no
not around here at least
what do you worry about
um
future generation really
because it's
yeah you know they
they don't work when you get older we
don't have you know
social security when we can't work
so yeah your child will have a hard time
yeah in 25 years
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um
probably that they can always get worse
if
you think you can't it can
that's for sure yeah when
there's a new new bottom yeah there's
always a new bottom you can't can't stop
going down but you can always rise up
do you have
what do you think's more likely that you
might oh have you odd before yeah
um i've ever ever noticed once it was
actually my sister's house i overdressed
at
i was dead i was dead for forfeit four
minutes and i came back after 30.
do you think it's more likely that
you'll
die from your drug addiction or or get
clean one day um
hopefully get clean but
i'll say there's like a 50 50 of me
dying
because it's just
the
thought of dying and don't outweigh the
drug for some reason
do you and your friends talk about how
how bleak
yeah things are of your generation and
what i mean what
are there any solutions anyone comes up
with or any ideas
you just
not really it's just
so especially when you're on drugs it's
just all they think all the person
thinks about you know it takes every
home
your whole life what does your typical
day look like you wake up and what
happens
try to find drugs first thing
that's
you know if that's
get get well don't get sick
and then
go on with my day it's basically your
whole your whole day just revolves
around yeah getting your fix yeah and
staying well yeah
yeah that'll destroy any chance of
having a job or
yeah it was so curious so if you don't
yeah if you don't get clean you don't
yeah you pretty much your life revolves
around it
it's such a beautiful part of the
country
yeah i know
it really is
it could be a better much better place
if
i don't know i i really don't know what
like besides
getting the drugs and stopping them from
get coming in because they're coming in
from detroit and other places i feel
like you know
they're coming in they're coming in all
late so you know i mean
there's bigger states all around us
do you have friends that have gotten
gotten away and
now friends just moved and stuff so they
got yeah they got a better life in other
states it almost seems like the only
solution right
and you get depressed sometimes i'm sure
yeah i have manic depression i'm bipolar
how is that right yeah you take
medication for that uh no i'm always
self-medicated yeah
the heroin kind of yeah helps with that
yeah it just knows everything so you
don't have any feeling
and that keeps you on the cycle yeah
sure
what kind of behavior i mean do you see
people like
doing sex work or any kind of stuff like
that to make money oh yeah i've seen
i've seen all kinds of stuff like i when
i was up in city park i see a girl get
shot in the face
um
because that's just a big part of
you know the drug game people get the
eye people
killed over them people get killed over
you know gang violence
up there in city park and so
but
yeah freaking i've seen girls
do all kinds of things for drugs and
like
you know i've never done i would just
you know if i had i've robbed people
yeah
but as i would never do no sexual favor
for drugs like but i would if i always
find my way you know i mean that's just
part of it i don't know
so i don't live at home in the morning
[Music]
i've been messed up things and yeah i
kicked out my home
uh went to city park and then after that
i just became homeless i had nowhere to
stay up there
all right cody well thank you so much
for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck all right
thank you thank you